trash arida biglieri orecchini borsetti
alle more chapelli diciamo arriva su
busta è ben accolta e poco dopo graham e
30 dei modi io per te punto amico 99
euro bella signora deve avere beni
brescia reti sceglier to scegliere lui
pagare tu devi avere fatto smontare
tutto tu non comprare niente
non si fa così come un sasso dopo l'era
borsa va bene va tutto bene questa 50
quale piace quale piace questo io sono
perchè tu belle ragazzino regalare ma
non dire nessuno sono 55 euro io avrei
detto regalo non aver detto regalo io ho
detto prova tu se ti piace poi pagare a
me 55 euro non è tanto facciamo 50 49 48
ora sto cazzo care toccare bellissimo
tessuto questo 7z 45 no domani io non
passare domani o riposare facciamo
sconto sconto amico 55 non vuole pagare
in cui chiedere lui marito serve per
questo tool pagare sempre no pagare
anche questo mustafa the necessity paga